guys age pretty well if they don't yeah
Tom Cruz looks great Tom Cruz is fake oh
yeah I don't know he's probably like
Paul brisy said he said man can you
imagine if it wasn't for Scientology Tom
Cruz would be the coolest guy who ever
lived that baby blood keeps you young
though yeah he's probably drinking some
yeah why not what is it called
adrenochrome that's the one yeah you
think that's true I don't think so no I
just like to joke but you know I'm in
Qing on so what the
hell with the TV just turned off the
whole van yeah we lost power in the van
oh [__] oh we lost power in the van
probably because of the heat are the
mics working yeah no M mics are plugged
into that big ass battery pack they're
listening to us they know you're saying
[__] yes Scientology Put A Spell On Us
you ever try to go to that building they
will kick your ass right out of there
somebody told me it's a hotel you can
stay in too no way and I said [__]
and he's like no I swear to God it's a
cheap hotel you can stay in it's
beautiful wow wa what's the billboard it
says uh are you curious why so many
people are
scientologists well it's an odd group
it's Tom Cruz number one I'm not
curious one I don't I don't think
there's really that many everybody's
falling out well the rumors they got
something on you like you tell them you
ran over a kid in 1984 and you know of
it yeah they get you out of it but they
go but we know so you got to stay in
this or we'll we'll leak it they get you
out of it I thought that their whole
deal was like okay now how Scientology
works is you tell us all the bad stuff
you've done yeah that's what I'm saying
and they get you out of it I didn't know
that well if you kill someone they cover
it's like right they own everything but
I mean look who Travolta kind of went
cuckoo Will Smith obviously is a Will
Smith S I didn't know that oh yeah
that's where that anger came from that
and his wife [__] other men
which is very well documented that's not
me
speaking Yeah there you go the red table
hor [__] yeah uh who else oh yeah that
uh Brook Shields oh yeah man that's sad
the that Z that 70s kid yeah the guy who
just got in trouble mcms was he sigh and
t uh Danny masteron I know so he left
Scientology and then now he's going down
then you had cour cases I don't know I
don't know I don't know if that's the
case I'm going Muslim I'm going to do a
curve ball going Muslim at the end yeah
your set would do great in the Middle
East oh yeah that would be fun I'll cut
my head off talk about Mohammad the
whole deal oh yeah they love that you
know Comics hear [__] about hey
cancelling and you can't say [__]
they'll cut your head off go do a
Muhammad joke over there they'll [__]
put a hot poker up your ass till you die
yeah you you had a a tweet that was so
funny to me it was a um Allah Akbar is
like let's go for white guys Allah yeah
let's go is Allah Allahu abbar for white
guys let's go white guys love saying
let's go yeah it's all hog bar yeah I
think the funniest tweet I ever read
please was by Jeff Ross okay okay he
tweeted this TMZ article it was like
that it was like the day it happened the
Magic Castle here at the uh the the
Magic Castle on Highland yeah and they
they found a
magician dead he had hung himself in a
closet at the Magic Castle all right and
um Jeff Ross tweeted the TMZ article
with his own little caption he says his
last words were Abra kadaver oh I love
it I love it just the day of I love a
good joke yeah my favorite meme was uh
the one where there's a video of trump
kind of like at the press conference
like and then he's just like did you
pull
out you know it's always like a funny
joke with like guy friends it's like do
you have sex out day and you know
they're like yeah like do you use a
rubber like no and everybody just laughs
I don't know why that's so funny that's
funny that's great I had one uh The
Bachelorette was coming on and they the
the headline was I don't know who New
York Post said uh was Bachelorette was
forced to choose a black woman you know
and I wrote
uh I and now now you know how I feel Das
Joe
Biden because of comma but I did it
right when that was all happening and
that that one really blew up that did
people like it or were they outraged
yeah a little both but that's you know
part of it did you have the joke in your
last special about the uh Miss Miss
America or Miss Universe that was trans
is that you I had a a Down syndrome
Victoria Secret model joke okay I had a
lot of those uh no I don't have the
trans one but that's true though right
there was a Victoria Secret model that
was had Down syndrome yes and she was
cute she's really pretty the joke was
I'd go Downs on her you know which is an
easy joke yeah and then I said I feel
sorry for the women the woman who didn't
get the job like I didn't get it who got
it you don't want to know kill yourself
get out of town change careers yeah good
times there a there a Down syndrome
Barbie now I mean they're having a
moment are they really have that good
for them yeah yeah why not yeah they
exist I don't think they're buying stuff
I mean you can give them just like a a
bucket of paste and they'll be happy but
uh you gave them some candy but yeah
good for them they're having a moment
yeah there's that like hidden camera
show where they where they jumped out
and they scared this lady walking by but
she had like some sort of down syndrome
and she was just like had a full [__]
meltdown and they're like oh my God I'm
so sorry I'm so sorry and like the lady
just flipped her [__] wow and it was
just the wrong person to [__] do that
to and they're strong you don't want to
[__] with them they'll flip a car over
oh yeah and then hump it um did you see
the Barbie movie I have not I would like
to but I have not seen it I like Margo
Rob I I've only heard positive feedback
really it seems like every chick I know
has seen it twice wow and every dude I
know who has seen it said good things
about it yeah yeah okay I heard it's
beautifully done I heard Ryan Gosling's
hilarious I heard it's Greta Gerwig
who's always good she directed it I
heard that Barbie is actually a doll in
the movie how's it how do you do that
it's like a real act liveaction movie
about a real doll really I didn't hear
that I don't know I that maybe Lux is
pulling my leg but she said that um it's
about she's an actually a doll in the
movie what about
Oppenheimer I saw it I I couldn't really
get into it come on really did you like
it I never saw it I haven't seen it
either but I'm excited I love Nolan I
love the story it it's not bad it's
Don't Tell Me How It
Ends it's not bad but I was just like
man you know like I'm the guy who
watches a movie movie that's based on a
true story and then goes immediately to
watch the do the Real documentary yes
which is always better yeah yeah and um
I was just kind of in the movie theater
thinking like man I'm like very
interested in like the documentary I'm
gonna like that a lot more yeah yeah
totally I heard it's it's do we need a
three-hour plus movie all we talk about
is our attention spans are going away
and now they're making movies
longer the the during the pandemic they
did the Martin score sayy was 4 hours oh
the Irishman [__] what are we doing here
it took me six times to watch yeah edit
the [__] what do you J appow cut it down
and uh the defense of Oppenheimer it did
not feel like 3 hours okay okay I had to
pee I did leave the theater to pee at
one point but did you go by yourself no
I went with Lux
IMAX I don't know no no climax we we did
the one um where you recline in the
seats oh those those big leather chairs
they sometimes they vibrate it's fun I
should have seen broke back in one of
those I'd get my ass pounded do you like
shopping on Amazon I do and good news is
sto's butt wipes for your butthole are
available on Amazon and if you want a
real bundle of a deal you can get sto's
hot sauce for your butthole plus sto's
butthole destroyer and sto's butt wipes
for your butthole it's the butthole
bundle available on Amazon right now
yeah dude